there are expected to be long lines this
morning in jackson mississippi as people
wait desperately for a basic human
necessity we're talking about water we
all take that for granted this is day
five of a growing crisis that has forced
schools and businesses to close now
residents are now being told to shower
with your mouth clothes because the
water is not safe elise press is in
elise preston is her name she's in
jackson with more on the story elise
listen this has nothing to do with the
story but i'm having a question in the
studio do you shower with your mouth
open in the first place
good morning elise uh no i do good
morning to you gail no i do not and it
is definitely not
advised here you see their trucks behind
me 600 national guard members have been
deployed here to jackson to help
distribute water to families here during
this crisis we were here at this mega
site yesterday and watched them pass out
nearly 5 000 cases of water to 2500
families
when we caught up with sharon dunson she
had not had usable water in her home for
more than a week what has that been like
it has been terrible like dunsen many in
jackson mississippi are still without
reliable drinking water despite crews
installing an emergency pump at the
city's deteriorating water treatment
facility it smelled like sewer the water
in 53 year old terry white's home is no
good she's concerned for herself and her
five-year-old grandson i can't flex the
toilet how does this all make you feel
well me it makes me angry we have low
running water to where we can't do
nothing it's frustrating it's wrong
and it needs to be fixed
mississippi governor tate reeves says
the focus in the short term is
distributing as much water as possible
to residents in need i just wanted to
help any way that we can enlisting the
help of the state's national guard this
is one of seven mega sites where the
national guard is handing out two cases
of water per adult we don't have the
built-in revenue that we need to keep
the system maintained anna wolfe has
been covering the water crisis for
mississippi today a non-profit news site
we've got failing pumps so that's the
mechanism that actually pumps the water
out of the reservoir which is where we
get our water from and puts it out to
customers the other is the treatment
mechanism so you know if the water is
not treated we can't push it out part of
the reason jackson doesn't have the
funds is because of a dwindling tax base
that goes back to the latter half of the
last century when the city saw an exodus
of white residents during integration as
our population has declined we haven't
had the tax base necessary to keep up
this really large system
heavy rainfall and flooding last week
placed a strain on the aging system
exacerbating long-standing issues with
the city's infrastructure fema
administrator deanne criswell told cbs's
nora o'donnell that the army corps of
engineers is among the agencies
inspecting jackson's water
infrastructure we have to focus on what
the future is going to have to be right
how are we going to make sure that this
doesn't happen again
now chris well is expected here today
and the national guard tells us it will
remain in jackson until orders change
meanwhile that water treatment facility
is going to take a long time to complete
repairs there so families will continue
battling fluctuating water availability
gail
i know it's an awful situation for the
people there at least thank you so much
it doesn't make any sense to me that
jackson mississippi as we're saying is
the capital of that state that people
are i'm assuming they're working 24 7 to
get it fixed but that it's taking this
long i mean it's so frustrating well and
then it's gotten to this point i mean
they've had a bunch of oil water notices
over in recent years i mean it's been
going downhill and like you know
electricity water these are basic things
you expect your government to provide
for you particularly in the capital of a
state in these united states in 2022.
the state is so incredibly poor it's at
the it's dead last on so many economic
indicators the state can't shore up
the necessary help that this city needs
so
it's tough it needs to be done there
sooner rather than later